welcome to this video some blitz action
here on the ICC five minute game okay I
wanted to go to the Leningrad touch and
case playing an interesting for Nia
allowing me to play a cookie fire
nothing I particularly fear yeah why
should I play g6 so I should i play with
bishop is a membership is seven years
also okay if he goes deform and i play
you for it looks at like reversed French
interesting yeah how to seller i guess i
should place his six at some point to
have d5 ready okay quincy to may be here
night might come to see 627 later
supporting d5 and it had some idea of
play night before okay how to how to
proceed he's not really clarifying his
intentions on the queenside III before
me can play before him okay he has not
castle yet that's also the curious k
quick before the night probably needs to
go here anyway I might have a five okay
no is castling interesting so on d4 i
have e for if he goes be five that's not
particularly threatened he can play c5
which i probably will just ignore man
let him take that's an interesting
position here
Queen eatum possibly allows Queen h5 at
some point among but not not easy to
accomplish is there some way to to get
get some activity goin ham yeah not sure
Queen maybe to h6 the possible possible
earth warm yeah there is no direct
pleasure forces in this position the the
whole setup that i have is geared
towards the King side so I'm getting the
Queen over them yes that that that was
clear that this is a viable option I was
always intending to just let him take
yeah probably here then let him take on
d6 if this happens the the bishop on d6
is nicely placed towards the edge to the
Kings side no I'm threatening me for
weather case prevented that ok but I
have some some ideas now ok I think I
should should take maybe not maybe not
maybe 94 immediately try to put some
pressure on the Kings side let me know
to take if I I take f 3 i'd like to
provoke some sort of porn like Age 3
this would be very helpful ok he's
played age three but there's nothing I
cannot really punish it at the moment
if I go back ok it's got Bishop c1
forcibly
m XX a slight problem sorry that's
really a problem shop c1
I go back Bishop c1 known and FYI slowly
move I really want to play ok we'll
probably take what the night it's very
very tricky position probably not a very
good one I a threatening to take on d6
and take on g4 very simple but possibly
also strong yeah I wanted to play 95 but
you can just take on d6
maybe I need your gamble with this 96 93
years some sort of attack like that
could be dangerous with Bishop h3 coming
this is so I don't know probably not
objectively working but it's not very
easy to play for white takes takes I
have 93 as well at the end of the meydan
g2 it's a very tricky position probably
the computer find some some reputation
but it looks dangerous to me there's
also Bishop takes g2 with a double check
and night is free winning the Queen's oh
I can take here now check and if he
takes with the King naughty three wins
the Queen so he probably has to move the
King now after which I have Queen III as
well like King John ok is giving jack
Queen son I'm taking this
the whole Highness is not not entirely
clear he's got some some stuff for the
Queen
and I only have one minute left so the
typical typical problem
it's not not so easy to play
how do you look fa 25 check this kind of
stuff could be good getting some some
sort of attack on the king the night on
h2 is shielding asking quite quite
reliably at the moment my night only
three is really a piece I need to use
Jack and Knight f6 cheekiest answer okay
that's not something I wanted to do
exchange the night but okay
30 seconds oh that's nice I can take it
you can take it because of the pillow
what you didn't see it
no I okay this pawn should decide the
issue I could examine could have taken
on g4 which would have been a real cool
i am him play this played this far too
quickly i can take now and then it's
it's it's entirely unsure what's going
on here i'm just i'm winning you with
with age 54 exam this is stronger if he
takes no AF Queen h7 Medicare needed to
move I need to move quickly of course
hard hard to tell all this I mean I sort
of stumbled into this position where
it's not clear what I should do mother
computer just wants to retreat yeah I
didn't want to do that I mean I wasn't I
was thinking he can play Bishop c1 and I
didn't want to play f4 f4 look I know I
didn't like it the computer ever thinks
after a four I'm perfectly all right
yeah maybe I am maybe I am what I didn't
really appreciate is one thing here I
always thought that if I go g5g I will
just play Knight h2 and cover this but I
have 96 to deform this is in fact quite
a quite an okay position from luck I
also always feared deform it's not so
quick to get in I mean okay this was a
misjudgment I thought that I needed to
move the Queen here or let's say f4 is
better but I thought that something like
that is this not really working or even
I even this one is in even worse and
therefore I thought okay I for was not
very good and ok misjudgment I took and
then then I went to went 4 for this but
it does not seem to work the computer
gives white the win here I was thinking
this is this is interesting but probably
not correct take stakes and the
computers killed
taking on age three okay now the problem
is that after ninety three days queen
bee three check this is the problem I
can do something like that but but he
has always this is checked which I
didn't really appreciate this is the
same thing he always has nice temple
yeah so this just wins for him and this
is probably a check yeah this is
probably losing he must go here of
course after which the computer is not
giving me a direct one just minus one
after here while I'm just I'm just
taking the Queen and this is the wind
probably but not not so easy okay huh i
miss Knight a one here this is stronger
because the night has no escape square
anyway yeah this is pretty clear on TI i
did it is a that compass minus 3 and
stuff but it's not so easy to do Jack I
made a mistake I can check here now
that's that's very difficult to see the
check and then this one that's very
difficult for human to see Buddha with a
vicious double attack it's the typical
case of those combining Queen use if you
have some time you you will see it but
it's not so easy with 30 seconds or what
I had on the clock ok this is this is
keeping some advantage but it is less
clear by far less clear yeah ok
difficulty with a little time
interesting game though thanks for
watching